Japan's biggest Bank Mitsubishi
Financial Group is gonna start using
robotic bank tellers that's right the
future is now people we've got some
video of the robots they're using this
is not at the bank this is video from a
couple years ago but these are the exact
models that they're going to be using
let's take a look
alright so for those of you that watched
show up and you know I love robots I
love talking about this futuristic stuff
so let's get a little more info on the
robots that they're actually going to be
using the robots are gonna be called now
although it's spelled n/a oh they can
speak up to 19 different languages they
can determine customer's emotions from
their facial expressions and they'll
greet customers and can tell them about
money exchanges ATMs opening bank
accounts or overseas remittance so I
kind of like this this is the future
everything is going to be robotic you
can't fight city hall people it's
happening but I could understand why
people might think this is a little
weird customer service with humans is
pretty terrible so is it just gonna be
worse with robots like how much more
robotic the humans that you talk to
usually especially you call Time Warner
sometimes I think I'm actually talking
to a robot but it actually is a human
apparently how do you feel about this
well I'm really excited because I've
been looking for a long time to meet a
banker just been looking all the wrong
places so I'm gonna be heading to Tokyo
this weekend you know it might be a
little bit of an issue if I wear heels
but other than that I'm psyched
you know full respect for these robots
yeah you're joking but I just watched
her this weekend you know that was
falling in love with AI yeah but I mean
that'll be the next step because AI is
gonna eventually be built into these
things freaky or cool I mean I think
it's pretty cool the fact that I can
read facial expressions might freak me
out a little bit yeah but I'm hoping
that it you know it makes things more
efficient I call a lot of times
different places and I even get the
automated system so hopefully it's not
that frustrating because you have to
repeat the same thing over and over and
over again and they never understand
yeah so I didn't make you type in your
phone number and then say your phone
over that's that's a good question while
he's I don't know yeah so if they if
they're better than that that'd be
awesome yeah what do you guys think our
fascination with artificial intelligence
is I mean we've been doing a ton of
stories on this Elan musk who's one of
the leaders in this just said a couple
weeks ago that he thinks it's basically
going to be the downfall of human
society and he's one of the people that
are actually promoting this but we have
human intelligence
that's pretty good right yeah why do we
need more I mean we are the Jetsons
let's face it we're on our way to the
judge yeah yeah I'd like to play Judy
still but no it's kind of it's cool and
it but it's also scary and I think we
are losing that element of real
face-to-face human contact although they
did describe this robot um he he greets
people with a hello and welcome that's
really breezy you know so I think that
that he's kind of the best of both
worlds like he's the smart guy right I
mean it's scary it's cool but I we got
to find a balance
yeah actually really need this so
speaking of balance every time I do any
of these future stories in the robot
stories I always ask when do you think
the robots will take over because it
seems to me I've watched enough sci-fi
movies
these robots it's gonna be good for a
couple years right and then we're gonna
need Will Smith to step in and stop the
evil robot entities from enslaving us so
what year do you think that's gonna have
it I want to know oh man I don't this is
gonna be on the internet forever until
the robots take it outside I mean I
don't want to make a prediction now
because if I'm wrong people just feel
like see we're wrong
and you're very science-based yeah the
thing is I mean you were talking about
human intelligence and stuff and that's
something I don't have a whole lot of
faith in so you know it might be sooner
than later that they're able to take
over yeah that's interesting so sort of
as a as a person that believes in
science and an atheist you could in a
weird way find more decency and
artificial intelligence perhaps
something that we sort of inner control
they're not they're not really like
self-aware not yet yeah but you know so
as far as that goes you can't really
compare yeah all right she's not giving
me a year out of here I take over and
this is why cuz there's a weakness
they're not gonna always understand that
emotional level because they can only
judge it by playing facial expressions
so you can always one-up them did you
guys ever play and my smiling or
frowning
you know like aha and this actually is
that the end scene at iRobot with Will
Smith when the robot winks at him
because it does learn so Oh
yelling or frowning I think your smile
ah alright there you go
will robots take over let us know in the
comments right down below